[Musik]
hallo als willkommens ellis welt heute
gibt es denn einen topf und zwar machen
wir ganz gerne im herbst aber ich muss
auch sagen ich jetzt auch im sommer ein
tipp für den ein tipp für finde ich gehe
einfach das ganze jahr
heute gibt es den linseneintopf und zwar
nennt sich das ganze eigentlich saure
linsen ist ein schwedisches gericht
jetzt rausgerutscht ist ein schwedisches
gericht und der murat mag es auch ganz
gerne
ich muss sagen ich habe das ganz lange
ich kann das nicht und dann habe ich
aber kennen gelernt und hab es dann auch
in das buch soll in trance gepackt das
war unser charity buch was wir eben
gemacht haben oder was ich gemacht habe
mit euren rezepten auch darin und da
ging er dann ein teil des erlöses an of
skaters sorgentelefon
und da habe ich das rezept auch mit drin
heute gibt es das rezept für euch jetzt
hier auf youtube und ich mache etwas
große menge damit wir alle was davon
haben und dazu werde ich dann noch
spätzle machen aber das findet ihr in
einem anderen video und und das ganze
ist sogar welche zur gucke fast re gaben
wenn man die butterweck lässt ihr könnt
der stadtbote einfach öl nehmen und dann
ist der eindruck wirklich wie kam und
dann könnte eben etwas anderes statt
später zu nehmen also ich brauche dafür
zwei zwiebeln knoblauchzehe ein bisschen
sellerie als knolle karotten
ich habe ich grüne linsen dann etwas
sonnenblumenöl 2 lorbeerblätter thymian
aus dem garten später für die
mehlschwitze dann butter und mehl
ich nehme hier etwas salz das sage ich
gleich was dazu ein bisschen apfelessig
und natürlich wasser also hier kurz
alles zur seite als ich habe auch
version gesehen da wird rauch speck mit
benutzt ich bin noch kein speck ich
wähle das ganze auch vegetarisch oder
vegan zu erhalten und habe jetzt hier
auch salz statt normalem salz so könnt
ihr auch ein raucharoma mit reinbringen
müsst ihr aber nicht ihr könnt doch ganz
normales salz benutzen also dass nur
auch salz mache ich heute auch
tatsächlich zum ersten mal was jetzt
mache ich werde erstmal die zwiebeln und
knoblauch fein hacken also schön würfeln
in der zwischenzeit gerne auch schon mal
das öl erhitzen einfach in einem großen
topf ich nehme jetzt hier den gusseisen
topf
[Musik]
schwäbisch sprichwort sagt die hemmnisse
nach zwiebeln rieche nach einmal
gelungene arbeitstag oder ja ja ich kann
es auch nicht auf hunde und was gibts
noch zu beachten
krupp wir in nrw die zivile lagern gab
es mal die werbung im schnitt nicht zu
alt dafür gab's mal so ein video dass
ich mal so fokussiert mensch nicht
dieses schon soviel millionen deutsche
können ich nicht nicht lesen und
schreiben
es gibt es in schwäbischer version und
verstand so dann schimpft damit eben und
sagte komm wir in einer zelle und dann
ist ebenso 80 millionen deutsche können
kein richtiges schwäbisch also jetzt die
zwiebeln anbraten immer mal wieder durch
röhren und der deckel drauf dann rechts
nicht so stark nach zwiebeln auch meine
augen
ich weiß ihr schreibt mir immer wieder
eure tipps rheinwasser im mund ich weiß
ich muss ich denke immer zu spät dran
und außerdem moderiert sich so schlecht
mit wasser im mund ist nicht so
oder taucherbrille auf sieht komisch aus
jetzt auch die karotten und den sellerie
schön feinschneiden einfach in feine
würfel
[Musik]
sarah du als waschechte schwäbin kann
schon mal kurz ins video komme com
saratow als waschechte schwäbin hier von
dir würde ich gerne wissen vorstand
wolle jobs sieht okay es war nicht die
frage also ok oh eine trage ich das
nicht ich werde keine produktplatzierung
machen eh was ich will
kannst du diesen werbespot dieses wie
oft habe ich sagt krumm während labour
zwiebel einlagern ja darum wäre das
heißt weiß die hälfte mich ja das heißt
er hilft nicht um revanche hat gerade
behauptet er kennt den spot nicht weil
er zu jung ist eine schlussfolgerung ich
bin so alt
hahahaha ja ich bin doch auch nur mit
anfangs mit 20 jährige ja wieso 220
jahre hammerhall bedacht wird später das
video zu ende
[Musik]
so ich hab jetzt einfach ein bisschen
mehr salär ihr ein als ich wollte aber
ich bin der sellerie coach deswegen
kommt aber 3 hier kommt das gemüse jetzt
einfach dazu
[Musik]
jetzt schön mit anbraten gerne sondern
minute ich gebe auch schon mal die
lorbeerblätter dazu und werde schon mal
die grünen linsen in einem sieb einfach
kurz abspülen
[Musik]
das riecht schon wunderbar kommen die
linsen dazu ich bin echt zum fan von
viel gemüse falls ihr jetzt mehr lesen
haben wollte weniger gemüse können dass
ich den gemüseanteil auch verringern
indem wir ist aus dem topf aber ich muss
schon sagen gemüse muss schon sein
musik von bekannten vitamine reihen gut
und hülsenfrüchte wie linsen für auch
super gesund
von daher wird es echt ein ganz ganz
tolles rennen heißt kurz mit anbraten
und jetzt kann ich hier direkt schon mit
dem wasser auf kritik
ich gebe jetzt noch kein salz dazu denn
salz bewegt dass die linsen eben nicht
so schnell gar werden es gebe eben erst
mal ganz zum schluss dazu verspritzen
faden verloren beim reden so aber dann
habe ich ihn wieder gefangen direkt auf
höchster stufe damit kochen kann
thymian aus dem garten kommt auch mit
rein und die restlichen zutaten warten
noch aufpassen
und da ist auch eigentlich eine ganz
gute info die linsen müssen jetzt nicht
komplett weich sein also die dürfen
schon noch ein bisschen bis haben so al
dente sein
das dauert jetzt ungefähr 15 bis 20
minuten und in der zwischenzeit nähe so
in zehn 15 minuten mache ich die
mehlschwitze ich mobil halten bisschen
ich habe zwar gesagt eintopf benutzen
zwei tage weil ich die mehlschwitze noch
macht ihr müsst sie nicht machen aber
ich finde wenn man jetzt ist er einfach
nur mit wasser verrührt und rhein gibt
für die bindung ist okay kann man machen
aber einen besseren geschmack gibt es
eben wenn man das mehl in der butter
noch ein bissle andünsten und deswegen
und zweite topf ich hoffe ihr verzeiht
mehr
so sieht es jetzt bereits aus ich finde
das sieht lecker aus
und jetzt kann ich hier in meinem
zweiten job board to board gericht
bereits die mehlschwitze machen das
heißt da kommt jetzt die butter rein und
noch einmal weniger machen wollt vegane
butter oder einfache leben das nähen
dazu und es wird dann schön angebraten
bis es so leicht hel frauen wird dadurch
verletzt den mail geschmack und bekommt
einfach ein schönes aroma ich nehme
jetzt hier schon mal die kräuter raus
gerne auch schon die lorbeerblätter raus
die will man auch nicht unbedingt mit
essen
ich mache den sturm und mache ist der
power boost schnell schnell schnell
schnell haben schmerzt ihn vielleicht
wieder runter von der power stufe
wenn es dann anfängt gut zu duften und
eben leicht bauern aussieht könnt ihr
hier von der brühe was dazugeben und
schön dabei rühren damit es nicht
gelingt
und dann kommt jetzt hier alles zu den
linsen dazu und es bindet daneben den
eintopf schön
damit es nicht so suppen artig ist
sondern wirklich so schön einen twist
und jetzt mit dem essig abschmecken dann
salz mir gesagt habe ich jetzt hier auch
salz senf dazu kam noch besser
abschnitten
und jetzt nur noch kurz erwärmen bis das
ganze eben bindet und dann ist der
linseneintopf im prinzip schon fertig
bei uns gibt es jetzt hier ganz
traditionell selbst gemachte spätzle
dazu da habe ich wie gesagt schon ein
eigenständiges video dazu und was auch
gut passt sind wienerle wir nehmen jetzt
inzwischen und die werde ich dann gleich
im spätzle wasser noch mit erwärmen und
dann kann schon probiert werden
barak angeles ja ich muss sagen als kind
hat es gehasst
ich glaube jeder hat es als gehabt aber
später lebt man meine meine mutter wird
mir immer an drehen dann habe ich mir
gesagt ne ersten beruf und dann
irgendwann bin ich älter bin älter und
schlauer und reifer und legt mehr wert
auf gesunde ernährung und dann habe ich
gemerkt grenzen sind eine super protein
würden wir sie überholte ihn quelle
deshalb essen essen wir lesen ja und
gucken dem buch habe ich als saurer
morath gemacht es habe sich aber der
guckt da gar nicht sauer und styling
note 6 aber dass sich auch ein
kinderbuch deswegen soll noch freundlich
ach so ja und ist von diesem bonus ich
probiere einfach ich bin gespannt wo ich
hab's aber noch nie mit karotten drin
zählen ja ich wollte halt noch
gemüseanteil finde ich dachte ich kurz
meinen lassen
eine fliege ich hier habt ihr wieder
auch das beste an einem kalten oder
warmen sommertag auch das beispiel weder
essen noch extra essig drauf dass ich
drüber ich tatsächlich auch ich würde
jetzt ja auch noch extra hin zu machen
weil das wirklich sauer
so mag es auch murat würde ich dazu so
ein rind zu essen ich finde es muss
nicht sein weil es ist so schon hier
wird auch der eintopf schon reichen also
und jetzt muss ich echt auch sagen denn
es ist ein sehr sättigend und sehr
leckeren protein reinigt und
proteinreiche wir wissen also probiert
das rezept gern mal aus vielleicht habt
ihr auch ein rezept was so typisch ist
für eure region also saurier linsen
glaube ich kennt man nicht überall watch
kann der student in baden-baden kennt
was macht max bayern bayer bayer mich
irgendwie dach bayern ja vielleicht habt
ihr ja auch so ein typisches gericht von
aus eurer region an schreibt doch gerne
in die kommentare und dann machen wir es
bei euch also viel spaß beim nachbarn
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]